خلينا نراجع سويا يعني السبعه ايام بصحبه
الحميه التي اقترحها
التي جاء فيها كالتالي اليوم الاول يجب ان
يعتمد على بعض الزبادي اليوناني واللوز
والخبز المحمص القليل من الدجاج والطماطم
وزيت الزيتون وعصير الليمون وسمك السالمون
انا سمعت يعني من اول يوم على كل حال في
اليوم الثاني مشاهديناها يحتوي ايضا على
العجه النباتيه ايضا خبز الحبوب الكامله
شرائح الدجاج المشوي السلطه الخضراء
والمشكله ايضا فضلا عن البطاطا الحلوه او
عفوا الخضره المشكله وايضا البطاطا الحلوه
والبروكلي طيب ثالث يوم يحتوي على رقائق
الشوفان بذور الشيا والخضروات وجبن الفته
والروبيان المشوي والحبوب الكامله اما في
اليوم الرابع يتكون من افوكادو وخبز محمص
وبعض شرائح اللحم المشوي وزيت
الثوم ايضا اليوم الخامس مفترض هذا اليوم
يحتوي على سبانخ الفطر البطيخ الخضروات
مشكله حمص اضافه لزيت الزيتون وسمك القد
المشوي اليوم السادس جعت انا بعد ما شبعت
باول يوم لانه اليوم السادس مشاهدينا بحسب
تشات
يدخل فيه الشوفان والخوخ والعسل واللوز
ايضا مع لفائف خضروات مشويه هذا بالاضافه
لدجاج مشوي وخضار مشوي ايضا اليوم السابع
وهو اليوم الجد خلاص اليوم السابع سنعود
للزبادي اليوناني ولكن بالعسل مع شرائح
اللوز وفلفل محشي بالكينوه وسلطه يونانيه
وسمك مشوي وقشر ليمون
والاعشاب مع ذرع مشوي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات تقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات